[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález millones de
refugiados miles de muertos entre
civiles y militares y un avance militar
muy lento que se ha prolongado a lo
largo de estas semanas es lo que deja
este primer mes de una incursión militar
y un conflicto que ha tenido lugar en la
región del este y en el centro de
ucrania un conflicto que tomó por
sorpresa prácticamente a la comunidad
internacional el 24 de febrero rusia dio
inicio a una ofensiva militar con miles
de tropas que desde la mirada de
occidente consistió en una invasión del
territorio de ucrania pero desde el
punto de vista ruso consistía
simplemente en una operación militar
para liberar a ucrania del nazismo
defense defender a los rusoparlantes
residentes en ucrania y también buscar
el fin de un gobierno nacionalista en
kiev veamos entonces cómo ha sido el
avance a lo largo de este primer mes
como lo decíamos el 24 de febrero las
tropas rusas comenzaron a avanzar desde
el este desde las autoproclamadas
repúblicas de doñetsk lugansk también
empezaron a avanzar desde la península
de crimea un territorio que ya había
sido a la federación de rusia desde aquí
empezaron a moverse hacia el norte del
país también llegaron tropas desde el
norte tropas rusas cruzaron el
territorio de belarús y empezaron a
bajar hacia el sur hacia el territorio
ucraniano desde la frontera hasta la
ciudad de kiev o'keefe que es la capital
ucraniana solamente hay 130 kilómetros
de distancia muy pronto los ataques se
concentraron en otras ciudades como por
ejemplo gerzón aquí en el sur con tropas
que venían desde crimen y hardcore o
kharkiv que es esta ciudad ubicada en el
noreste del país muy cerca a la frontera
rusa a propósito en la segunda ciudad
más grande de ucrania y también tiene
una población de mayoría rusoparlante
precisamente el avance buscaba moverse
hacia el centro del país para llegar y
capturar a kiev que es la gran conquista
que deben hacer las tropas rusas pero
también el asedio comenzó en otras
ciudades del país principalmente en la
ciudad de mariupol este es un importante
puerto ubicado en el mar de azov una
ciudad que ha sido cercada dando origen
a unos lamentables ataques jon al
lamentable crisis humanitaria el lento
avance de las tropas llegó a otras
ciudades como melitópol también aquí en
el sur y también a otras ciudades como
sapo línea en donde hay una importante
central nuclear que abastece de energía
a buena parte del territorio ucraniano
desde jarc eve y zoom y aquí en el norte
del país comenzaron a moverse más tropas
hacia el centro comenzaron a acercarse a
la ciudad de kiev y también comenzaron a
haber algunos ataques en el oeste en la
ciudad de lviv que hasta el momento
estaba en una relativa calma y también
comenzó a haber un asedio desde el mar
negro a la ciudad de odessa que es un
importante puerto ucraniano en el mar
negro como ustedes ven en el este
solamente faltaría esta franja de acá
para que las tropas rusas hayan
conquistado prácticamente toda la
frontera norte y este de ucrania sin
embargo las conquistas rusas se han
ubicado como lo decíamos en puntos
específicos en el sur en esta parte del
este y allí en el norte falta todo el
oeste del país y esta costa del mar
negro todavía sigue sin ser conquistada
por las tropas rusas si bien el ejército
ucraniano es más pequeño y menos
tecnificado que él la resistencia ha
sido fuerte incluso han realizado
ofensivas en algunas zonas que han
permitido recuperar terreno por parte de
las tropas ucranianas las consecuencias
de esta guerra son incalculables no sólo
por el daño a la infraestructura en
ucrania las consecuencias económicas
sino por la crisis humanitaria que ha
desencadenado hay millones de
desplazados internos y de refugiados
también que han buscado ponerse a salvo
en otros países generando uno de los
mayores éxodos desde la segunda guerra
mundial veamos entonces algunas de las
cifras en solamente cuatro semanas acnur
estima que 36 millones de personas
procedentes de ucrania se han convertido
ya en refugiados la mayoría de ellos han
llegado a polonia alrededor de dos
millones cien mil personas han llegado a
este país de la unión europea que es el
principal destino de los ucranianos
antes de la invasión ya en polonia
residían cerca de dos millones de
ciudadanos ucranianos que estaban allí
buscando mejores oportunidades laborales
rumanía acá en el sur ha recibido poco
más de 500.000 le siguen moldavia que es
este pequeño país de acá que con mucha
limitación y muchas dificultades porque
es un país muy pobre con muchos
problemas económicos ha recibido más de
372 mil
refugiados procedentes de ucrania le
sigue hungría también parte de la unión
europea con más de 320.000 también a
rusia han llegado más de 271.000 porque
porque muchos ciudadanos ucranianos
tienen también ciudadanía rusa o tienen
familia en este país y por eso se vuelve
en un destino también para ponerse a
salvo eslovaquia ha recibido más de 256
mil y belarús en el norte un poco más de
4.900 personas otros han llegado a otros
países han llegado a otros puntos de la
unión europea a través de estos países
han sido sus primeros puntos de partida
y de allí saltan a otros países de la
unión europea como alemania o como
portugal o incluso a países un poco más
allá de las fronteras europeas como eeuu
canadá kazajistán armenia e israel'
si hay una ciudad que ha sufrido el
asedio de las tropas rusas es
precisamente el puerto de mariupol en el
mar de azov allí las tropas rusas han
cercado la ciudad y han provocado una
gran destrucción de la infraestructura
de esta ciudad a través de los
corredores humanitarios la mayoría de
sus habitantes han podido escapar la
mayoría de ellos huye hacia el norte
hacia la ciudad de sap orilla a unos 120
kilómetros de distancia allí estuvo a
nuestra enviada especial catalina gómez
y conoció de primera mano las
experiencias las historias de vida de
estas personas que han huido del asedio
de mario volvemos las palabras no son
necesarias para narrar la tragedia que
se vive en agricole la pesadilla vivida
en las últimas semanas está reflejando
el rostro de quienes logran alcanzar la
población de sap orilla el primer puerto
de llegada de quienes huyen de la ciudad
[Música]
es terrorífico solo terrorífico
y por eso todo esto es tan difícil
muchas de las personas que han llegado
hasta que llevan días sino semanas
viviendo en refugios antiaéreos y para
salir de mario port ha sido otra tortura
porque muchas veces no salen
directamente sino que han ido de
población en población esperando que se
abran esos corredores humanitarios para
poder llegar hasta aquí
anastasia unido con su hija y su marido
dice que mariupol es hoy una ciudad de
la que no queda rastro los que
permanecen allí sobreviven con los pocos
alimentos que les quedan
ni siquiera puedo poner las palabras
juntas todo está destruido completamente
los barrios en la ciudad están
totalmente por los suelos
el terror de lo que han vivido en el
último mes no termina al llegar a un
lugar seguro la mayoría ha dejado parte
de los suyos atrás
después de muchos intentos
este grupo de 50 vehículos ha conseguido
permiso para hacer la ruta de regreso
dmitri va camino a rescatar a sus padres
de quienes no tienen noticias de más de
20 días creemos que hay muchas familias
atrapadas con niños y muchos tienen
problemas de estómago porque han estado
tomando el agua de las fuentes y tienen
infecciones cada uno de ellos tiene un
mapa que les muestra el acceso a la
ciudad pero una vez adentro deberán
enfrentarse al peligro por su cuenta
lugar hoy en día otra realidad su casa
en militó font ocupada por las fuerzas
rutas cuando tomaron el control de la
ciudad
les dijimos que era nuestra casa les
pedimos que se fueran pero ellos tomaron
todo lo que quisieron destruyeron
nuestras pertenencias rompieron las
cerraduras se comieron nuestra comida
nosotros tomamos algunas de nuestras
pertenencias y partimos
van camino al oeste en ucrania pero nos
acompaña el dolor de lo que han dejado
atrás no saben si podrán regresar y si
lo hacen se preguntan interesados lo
encontrarán
el informe de catalina gómez ángel
nuestra enviada especial a ucrania
mostrándonos la situación que se vive en
la ciudad de sapo niña con todas estas
personas que han logrado escapar del
asedio de la ciudad de mariupol pues
bien está la situación un mes después de
haber comenzado esta incursión militar
rusa está ya llamada por occidente una
guerra desatada en el territorio
ucraniano y para analizar este tema
saludamos a alexis o te quita que él es
analista político internacional del
'think tank' arrastra el se encuentra en
la ciudad de kif en la capital de
ucrania y en la ciudad de buenos aires
en argentina está andrés servín él es
doctor en ciencias políticas y analista
internacional también es presidente del
teem tanque regional crisis ustedes
también pueden ser parte de ésta
de esta conversación participen con
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram también en twitter estamos
como france24
s santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios y
preguntas relacionados sobre este tema
comienzo entonces en el debate con el
xxi en la ciudad de kiev la capital
ucraniana
preguntándole por este mes de guerra
este mes de incursión militar rusa en su
país rusia tal parece que no alcanza el
objetivo creían que iban a tener una
guerra un poco más rápida un poco más
ágil y les iba a permitir permitir
capturar kiev en un tiempo récord pero
no ha sido así
el ejército ucraniano ha dado la batalla
a su balance de este mes de combates
hola buenas tardes a todos ya todas a mí
me gustaría decir que es interesante ver
como ustedes hacen dos nombres dos
versiones de las ciudades ucranianas por
ejemplo bajar archivo jarkko yo creo que
ustedes pueden no gastar su tiempo y
decir realmente la forma ucraniana aquí
con el griego jarque como schmitz
observación personal bueno si hablamos
del mes de la guerra que llevamos ya
obviamente que usted tiene muchos
problemas en sus avances por muchos por
muchas razones por falta de comunicación
entre diferentes unidades por falta de
comunicación entre diferentes tipos de
ejército por ejemplo entre artillería
infantería tanques buques etcétera
también lo que hemos visto que la
resistencia civil ucraniana es muy
fuerte es muy dura y no solamente en la
parte de la sociedad que ayuda al
ejército para por ejemplo llevar
chalecos antibalas y lleva comida ropa
es necesaria a los soldados sino también
la resistencia es civil en las zonas
ocupadas como gerson como melitópol
donde la gente sale cada día y protesta
de forma muy muy dura contra los lados
rusos
y le hago la misma pregunta andrés en la
ciudad de buenos aires- sus impresiones
sobre este mes de incursión militar rusa
o de guerra conflicto como desde su
perspectiva debe ser llamado este
enfrentamiento en ucrania
bueno creo que es evidente que ha habido
una de una guerra que ha iniciado rusia
en ucrania
yo creo que hubo un cálculo que ha
fallado en menos de qué celeridad
podrían avanzar en la ocupación de
ucrania y eventualmente en plantearse
algún tipo de escenarios de transición
por parte de rusia ya colega mencionado
alguna de las fallas yo no soy un
experto militar pero algunas de las
fallas en términos de cómo ha funcionado
el avance ruso del avance militar ruso
como tal pero yo creo que esto va a
tener ya un mes marca muy claramente
toda una serie de repercusiones
específicamente en ucrania el drama
humanitario que estamos viviendo y
además es la resistencia que se está
evidenciando por parte del gobierno y de
la sociedad civil ucraniana por parte de
rusia yo creo que empieza a haber
ciertos cuestionamientos y cada vez más
amplios y con mayor resonancia sobre el
esta guerra y sobre el sentido
está de guerra iniciada por putin como
ustedes bien saben en estos días ese día
vio la serie de renuncias empezando por
su vice que fue la figura clave de la
transición la perestroika que ha estado
en el gobierno de la presidenta al banco
central y así sucesivamente
si veo que usted me quiere afrontar otra
cosa adelante si quiero quiero hacerle
una aclaración nada alexis porque él
comenzó su intervención hablando de la
forma como estamos pronunciando los
nombres de la ciudad de rosas quiero
aclararle y también a la audiencia que
nosotros no tomamos partido por ninguno
de los dos lados que están enfrentados
en esta en este conflicto simplemente
nos regimos de acuerdo a las reglas que
impone la real academia la lengua
española que estipula que el nombre de
la capital de ucrania es quiere porque
la pronunciación en ucraniano kif no
tiene una forma para ser no tiene grafía
en español para ser escritas a la
explicación quedan allí y por eso en
español se dice kiev yo hago la salvedad
y pronuncio los dos nombres porque
precisamente sé que esto genera
controversia porque puede darse a
entender que tenemos parte de algún lado
pero no estamos de ninguno de los dos
lados precisamente queremos analizar el
tema desde todos los puntos de vista y
por eso voy a seguir diciendo kiev
equipo hardcore y jarkiv porque
simplemente para evitarnos el problema
pero la cadena france 24 español tiene
una ley clara y es regirse de acuerdo a
las leyes de las reglas que impone la
real academia de la lengua española pasó
entonces a preguntarle a oleksiy sobre
lo que ha sido este mes lo que significa
para ucrania destrucción de ciudades
destrucción de infraestructura
en daños de infraestructura innecesaria
como los acueductos los sistemas de
energía los hospitales diferentes redes
de
hospitales a nivel
general en las diferentes ciudades del
país la destrucción va mucho más allá de
lo que estaban esperando los ucranianos
de lo que podría hacer esta incursión
militar rusa esta invasión a su
territorio cuál es la evaluación que
hacen de los daños
unas hablamos en general de los daños
que la federación rusa ha causado en
ucrania lo que conocemos por ahora es
que destruyeron cerca de
44 mil 500 casas de residenciales cerca
de 200 hospitales cerca de 150 escuelas
son los datos como más últimos que yo he
visto escuchar las noticias y en general
ucrania va a perderse entre 30 y 60 por
ciento de su de su producto interno
bruto y si calculamos eso en cifras
absolutas será la pérdida cerca de 300
billones de dólares entonces entendemos
que para ucrania esa guerra llevó las
consecuencias gravísimas y necesitaremos
por lo menos cinco años de las
inversiones directas enormes tanto por
ucrania sino también para por la parte
de la unión europea por la parte de la
comunidad internacional y de las
reparaciones por parte del uso porque
obviamente que ese país tiene que pagar
por su agresión por las destrucciones
que han causado y entendemos que esa
recuperación
después de la guerra
tiempo andrés desde el lado occidental y
este lado del mundo se habla de una baja
moral de las tropas rusas un lento
avance y múltiples dificultades para el
suministro de las tropas son datos que
muchas veces no se pueden comprobar pero
lo que nos está indicando es que esta
guerra tal vez se va a extender más de
lo que estamos pensando rusia está
avanzando muy lento en ese objetivo es
parte de la estrategia que análisis hace
usted si esta demora es parte de la
estrategia o si es que de verdad las
tropas rusas están teniendo problemas
para cumplir sus objetivos militares
pero yo creo que hay los medios en
general están concentrados obviamente
con el drama humanitario que se está
viviendo en ucrania y están concentrados
en cómo avanza o deja de avanzar la
guerra tal vez deberíamos estar viendo
cómo avanzan o no avanzan las
conversaciones para llegar a algún tipo
de salida a esta situación y yo creo que
eso es lo más preocupante que están
paralizadas las conversaciones más allá
de que la estrategia rusa sea seguir
avanzando con los criterios que tienen
en este momento
sobre el territorio ucraniano o no lo
que creo que es importante cómo se sale
de esta situación y para salir de esta
situación
necesariamente tienen que mantenerse no
solamente los canales diplomáticos para
seguir negociando sino que además debe
desarrollarse algún tipo de sesión de
lado y lado con respecto a los puntos
más álgidos de la negociación y yo no
percibo que eso se esté dando con lo
cual vamos a tener una continuidad de la
parte bélica en detrimento de la parte
diplomática mientras ya que usted se me
adelanta un poco y habla de esa mesa de
diálogo que tiene pocos avances ha
habido varios encuentros y se han
pactado algunas cosas interesantes como
los corredores humanitarios para sacar a
los civiles de puntos estratégicos como
es el caso de mariupol en el mar de azov
las mesas de diálogo han dado pocos
resultados
alexis su impresión y su opinión sobre
estas mesas de diálogo que tanto puede
haber por parte de ucrania para acceder
un poco frente a las exigencias rusas y
que tanto está dispuesto también rusia a
ceder para poder llegar a un punto de
acuerdo
yo creo que aquí la situación es
bastante fácil y sencilla porque
necesitamos tener claro una cosa así
mientras rusia tenga reservas para
lanzar nuevas ofensivas y mientras
ucrania tenga espera para resistir si
queremos en combate es que rusia sigue
con las demandas inestables para ucrania
reconocer la ocupación de crimea
reconocer las repúblicas separatistas
donde rusia empezó la guerra y que rusia
misma creyó no es completamente estable
para ucrania ceder nuestro ejército y lo
que dicen sobre la desmilitarización y
graña pero por qué porque tenemos que
quedar dejar nuestro ejército y vivir
sin él cuando ya nos atacaron una vez a
pesar de las garantías de seguridad que
tuvimos a pesar del dirección 3 nadal
etcétera etcétera entonces obviamente
que las demandas que de forma pública
anuncian los altos funcionarios de uso
del presidente ruso son inaceptables
también ucrania por ahora no está en la
situación para acceder algo para decir
que si nos rendimos no tenemos fuerzas
para resistir y por eso ningunas
negociaciones ni primera ni segunda ni
tercera ronda creamos hemos tenido
llevo y nos va a llevar a algún alto al
fuego algún armisticio lo único que sí
pudieron hacer es un pequeño intercambio
de prisioneros de guerra que sucedió hoy
cambiaron y creo que diez presentes de
que roque nos contra 9 ó 11 rusos más
buenas así y es casi casi lo único si
andrés con este panorama en de las mesas
de diálogos donde hay pocos avances está
aquí la
diplomacia agotándose un poco necesita
tal vez esta mesa de diálogo entre moscú
y kiev
o'keefe en un impulso por parte de la
comunidad internacional digamos eeuu o
la unión europea para darle un impulso a
esas negociaciones y que la diplomacia
pueda hacer ese camino de salida a este
conflicto
pero lo primero que quisiera recordarle
que la comunidad internacional no se
reduce a la parte occidental y de hecho
las conversaciones se han venido
desarrollando en turquía yo creo que hay
otros actores que podrían contribuir a
avanzar en algún tipo de conversaciones
que lleven a lugar al cese del fuego en
primer lugar y desde luego algún tipo de
acuerdo de paz y en esto yo creo que un
factor determinante son algunos países
asiáticos que no están considerados
dentro de la perspectiva de lo que se
llama a la comunidad internacional
occidental entonces yo creo que eeuu en
una posición en la otan tiene una
posición la unión europea con sus
altibajos y algunas diferencias tiene
una posición coinciden pero tenemos una
serie de actores que en realidad superan
la población a lo que consideramos
occidente que deberían tener algo que
decir en este sentido de ayudar a
construir la paz y voy a mencionar uno
solo que ha sido ya puesto en la tapa de
los medios y es china cuál es la
posición de china china podría
facilitaron a un avance en términos
relativos si tuviera un compromiso mayor
con el sistema internacional así como
está establecido o china va a permanecer
en una neutralidad más o menos activa
que en realidad te implica algún tipo de
apoyo a rusia bueno todas esas son
preguntas en el sentido de que si
pudiéramos incorporar a otros actores en
el proceso de facilitar la conversación
el diálogo y la negociación entre
ucrania y rusia tal vez podríamos
arribar más rápidamente a un cese al
fuego y algún tipo de acuerdo que quizás
se implique retornar a alguno de los
planteamientos de los acuerdos de min 1
y 2 bajo otra forma y con otros garantes
internacionales
sí no estoy diciendo que la comunidad
internacional quiere reducir a eeuu ya
la unión europea dije la comunidad
internacional por ejemplo algunos de
ellos puede ser eeuu o la unión europea
que son los que más han estado
involucrados en este conflicto pero
claro hay otros países como por ejemplo
turquía que se ha mostrado muy abierta a
negociar a hacer garante de estas
negociaciones y hay varios países que lo
han demostrado así algo que nos ha
llamado la atención a lo largo de este
mes de conflicto allí en ucrania es la
guerra mediática ese discurso que ha
habido desde todos los bandos
desinformación por todos los lados tanto
de occidente de los medios europeos de
los medios en américa también en china y
por supuesto en rusia vimos el caso de
la censura algunos periodistas
internacionales en territorio ruso y por
supuesto toda esta controversia de la
desactivación de la señal de rt y de los
servicios de sputnik en europa y en eeuu
y también en algunas partes de américa
latina'
o lex y su impresión sobre esta guerra
que se está librando a nivel mediático
es otro escenario de guerra es otro
frente que se abre que también involucra
al presidente selenski con unos mensajes
muy nacionalistas que ya lo califican
como un héroe nacional que ha logrado
unificar a los ucranianos y que ha
llevado a que se gane el respeto a nivel
internacional pero también tiene un
cierto grado de propaganda a todos estos
mensajes
a mí me gustaría mucho verlos los
ejemplos muy claros de cómo los medios
occidentales o latinoamericanos
americanos hacen las propagandas o
distribuir el distribuyo de
desinformación porque lo que vemos es
que rusia es la parte que siempre mentía
a su pueblo ya todo el mundo y sigue
mintiendo los ejemplos claros putin dice
que no va a cambiar la constitución
putin decía que no quiere ocupar crimen
putin dice que no tiene ningunos
ningunas pretensiones territoriales
hacia ucrania putin dice que no va a
subir la edad máxima para jubilarse y lo
que hizo hizo todo lo que decía que no
va a hacer estos ejemplos muy claros
muestran que rousseff tienen la máquina
de propaganda y de mentira más fuerte en
el mundo
lo segundo es que si en el mundo
occidental digamos bloquearon los
canales como sputnik erte etcétera y yo
creo que es la decisión correcta porque
porque estos canales no llevan ninguna
información útil digamos porque
ellos
utilizan la libertad de expresión para
distribuir el lenguaje de odio y de
guerra obvia para todo el mundo el
primero es que el blanco de es el
lenguaje de guerra y de odio a veces
ucrania el segundo es que dicen que van
a conquistar destruir hacer la guerra
nuclear contra polonia contra países
bálticos contra alemania francia
etcétera entonces es la protección para
la parte de la comunidad occidental
bloquear esta estas estas fuentes de
desinformación claro es que vemos desde
mosco un discurso muy claro se hablaba
de desnazificación del territorio
ucraniano de una operación para liberar
a ucrania y también viendo algunos
reportajes de rt en español cuando se
habla de las incursiones militares y de
la cantidad de muertos que han dejado
todos estos operativos nunca se menciona
quién los está perpetrando simplemente
se habla de personas que han fallecido
en operativos militares pero no dicen
quiénes son los que están perpetrando
estas operaciones hablo de reportajes
muy puntuales que han presentado de la
ciudad de mariupol que es tal vez la
ciudad más afectada por estos combates
andrés opinión sobre esto 'guerra
mediática' lo que ha implicado para
todos los enfrentados allí y como queda
occidente censurando los medios rusos y
suspendiendo la señal de estos canales
pero no de la censura de alguna manera
es previsible porque va de ambos lados
obviamente en el caso de rusia una
censura extremadamente fuerte pero no
tanto solamente eso sobre los medios
occidentales y sobre las redes
occidentales sino particularmente sobre
los propios rusos que están en contra de
la guerra y esto es un dato muy
importante porque no nos olvidemos que
aquí no hay una posición monolítica con
respecto a la guerra de apoyo a putin
pero yo creo que es necesario entender
algo y no quiero aquí polarizar ni
discutir en términos de este lado del
otro lo que quiero plantear es que ya lo
planteé en varios artículos míos la
primer víctima de la guerra es la verdad
y las dos partes generalmente de una u
otra manera distorsionan la información
y la utilizan en su provecho algunos de
una manera mucho más abierta mucho más
radical como lo estamos viendo en el
caso de de rúsia muchas veces pero si
nosotros vemos un poco hacemos un
pantallazo de los medios en eeuu
inclusive vamos a ver que hay
contradicciones y desmentidos entre los
propios medios
lo que puede ser una cadena que responde
más a la orientación liberal o provider
de una cadena que responde más a una
posición pro trump y entonces hay
cuestionamientos varios y además
planteamientos muy distintos sitios
escuchados en la cadena en una cadena no
no voy a mencionarla porque no viene al
caso en eeuu
tajantes declaraciones acerca de que la
guerra estaba terminada y putin había
ganado la guerra
bueno creo que hay algunos elementos es
necesario tener más evidencias como para
tener hacer este tipo de afirmaciones
entonces lo que yo insisto es que en la
guerra parte de la guerra es el juego de
la desinformación de ambas partes
importante ese punto que usted aclara
andrés efectivamente la verdad es la más
afectada en este en este enfrentamiento
de en realidades y discursos por parte
de los que están enfrentados
precisamente en este conflicto llamamos
también un mes de sanciones contra el
gobierno ruso sanciones contra el
gobierno de belarús andrés sacó la ronda
a la inversa para conocer su opinión es
suficientemente
es suficiente de este tipo de sanciones
para detener a putin en esta avanzada
militar en calmar un poco los ánimos del
gobierno ruso con todas estas
aspiraciones es suficiente este tipo de
sanciones que incluso al día de hoy
impusieron más
no yo creo que no son suficientes porque
la lógica a la que responde putin no es
una lógica
digamos económica no es una lógica que
responde a qué va a pasar en términos de
las sanciones económicas una lógica de
poder que está muy claramente planteada
en términos de asegurar su área de
influencia en
el marco europeo entonces en ese
contexto las sanciones han tenido un
impacto sin la menor duda en la economía
rusa
probablemente
parcialmente rusia estaba preparado para
eso probablemente rusia también putin
específicamente tiene expectativas de
poder sustituir algunos de sus socios en
el ámbito occidental por otros socios
para poder salir de las sanciones por
ejemplo el juego está en una expectativa
de reemplazar estas sanciones que se
dieron al swift con el sistema el
sistema similar que ha desarrollado
china que es el sips peruano son estas
son todas especulaciones en este momento
lo que sí sabemos es claro ha habido
impacto de las sanciones y segundo lugar
mucho más importante yo creo que las
sanciones han sido un boomerang porque
también han tenido un impacto negativo
sobre la economía mundial y las
economías occidentales
directamente a pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa oleksiy su opinión
sobre estas sanciones contra el gobierno
ruso
en general vemos que de verdad si
funcionan y lamentablemente las naciones
no tienen los efectos en corto plazo
pero si vemos que van a tener los
efectos más duros en corto en medio
plazo y que si ya los precios de
diferentes bienes en rusia crecieron en
unos casos cinco veces siete veces diez
veces que el tipo de interés de rublo
cayó como des dos besos por lo mínimo
que casi destruyeron a las acciones en
el mercado de bursa de bolsa en rusia
entonces en ese sentido
sigues hasta que nuestros necesarias si
estas sanciones son duras
lamentablemente si tienen como ese
efecto de un grano como ha dicho el
señor servín pero ese es el precio que
paga el
occidente digamos para detener esa
agresión rusa porque para nosotros queda
claro y que ucrania no es el punto final
de esa agresión ya debo finalizar el
programa quiero cerrar con la crisis
humanitaria la cantidad de ucranianos
que han abandonado el país cuanto más
pueden soportar países como moldavia
como rumanía recibiendo a estos miles de
ucranianos
esta crisis muchos organismos
internacionales dicen que apenas está
comenzando alexis su opinión sobre esta
situación humanitaria cuanto más puede
soportarse y ya con esto finalizamos
según los datos que recibimos a ucrania
abandonarán cerca de 3.5 millones de
habitantes yo creo que en ese sentido no
tenemos que preocuparnos mucho por los
países como moldova como polonia porque
a menudo los granos salen por estos
países pero después van a otros países y
por ejemplo si tenemos datos que a
polonia y ya salieron cerca de 2.3
millones de ucranianos pero ellos
manejan después a la otros países y ya a
controlar a contar cuántos sucre - se
fueron a alemán en cuanto se fueron a
francia a españa a otros países es muy
difícil porque ya no tienen fronteras en
esa zona y entonces ya lamentablemente
si si los combates siguen vamos a tener
más refugiados y si tomamos en cuenta la
cantidad de tiempo que pasó solamente un
mes y cantidad de gente que salió que
emigró entonces y de verdad es la crisis
migratoria más grande la haya visto
europa después de la segunda guerra
mundial andrew su opinión sobre este
tema humanitario y sobre esas críticas
sobre toda la unión europea que ahora le
abre las puertas a los ucranianos pero
meses atrás
las puertas a los migrantes procedentes
de siria de irak o de países del norte
de áfrica que también intentaban llegar
a la unión europea
correcto estoy de acuerdo con usted aquí
no hay digamos no hay manera de
establecer un equivalente ha sido mucho
más abierta a la unión europea frente a
este drama humanitario que se está
produciendo en ucrania que frente a lo
que ha pasado en otras regiones pero yo
quisiera remarcar en función de esto más
allá del drama humanitario que es
terrible lo que implica en términos de
las consecuencias para europa tiene de
europa la capacidad de absorción de tres
millones y medio de ucranianos el
financian tiene el financiamiento
va a generar esto algún tipo de
repercusiones políticas en términos de
los movimientos más nacionalistas y
xenófobos que ya se han expresado en su
momento con los refugiados de cydia o de
otros lugares van a pasar algún tipo de
situaciones graves en términos de la
seguridad todos sabemos que en este
momento uno de los grandes problemas de
los migrantes y que se encuentran no
tanto en polonia pero particularmente
es el tema del tráfico de personas
entonces cómo va a manejar eso la unión
europea hasta ahora vemos que lo están
trabajando básicamente las
organizaciones no gubernamentales pero
no hemos visto políticas gubernamentales
para abordar este problema que es un
problema dramático y que va a agigantar
lo que ya se está produciendo con el
desplazamiento lo estamos solamente
viendo desde la punta de la jce ver a
andrés sin duda alguna esto va a generar
consecuencias mucho más adelante andrés
y oleksiy les agradezco por haber estado
con nosotros en el programa hoy se nos
fue el tiempo más rápido que que en los
otros episodios les agradezco por haber
hecho este análisis para la audiencia de
france 24 y ustedes pueden seguir en
sintonía de france 24 y también hay más
noticias en france 24 punto com
[Música]